bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale des
leçons la ccn l'âge d'or aujourd'hui
l'ouverture avec 6 pouces et quatre
armes très dangereuses armes très
tranchante pour analyser cette ouverture
nous avons la présence de stéphane
laborde bonjour stéphane vouloir cette
variante avec vous ces 4 qu'est ce que
tu peux nous en dire
ben c'est la variante fétiche de fisher
bobby fischer champion du monde en 72
qui l'a utilisé maintes et maintes fois
et il avait des ses propres idées sur
cette variante avec les noirs aussi
d'ailleurs
elles craignent aussi puisque bobby
fischer était un très très grand joueur
d'un âge d'or également donc il avait
choisi son arme pour affronter sa propre
défense c'est toujours un petit dilemme
chez un joueur et il avait donc choisi
six pouces et quatre armes d'attac armes
très très forte très très efficace très
rapide surtout donc tout de suite action
avec des parties choisies des parties
commentées et surtout nous allons vous
conseiller une variante pour les noirs
une variante assez intéressante
cela dit alors tout de suite l'échiquier
c'est parti nous allons vous détailler
les premiers coups les blancs vous
attaque car rappelons le vous avez les
noirs vous jouez c5
la sicilienne donc jusque là stéphane
rien de nouveau à nouveau sous le soleil
cavalier f3 des six le coup qui vous
permettra de jouer un âge d'or donc on
rappelle pour ceux qui ne l'auraient pas
encore assimilé que si on joue qu'avec
ses six coups qui alors que naturel et
bien on perd énormément en souplesse et
on ne peut plus jouer la nage tort
puisque l'idée de la nature et de ne pas
mettre le cavalier en ces sites font une
des idées des six des quatre cécilienne
ouverte
ça prend des cartes dit captivée par des
quatre sets les six normales
thales perd 4 à 6 et c'est là stefano 6e
coup que les blancs ont le plus de choix
possible alors on va rappeler en
quelques lignes
quels sont les choix blanc dans cette
position il y en a vraiment beaucoup
d'indiens effectivement ce coup fous ces
et aussi le couffo 3 on a déjà des
tensions observées
il ya également le coup f4 qu'on
regardera plus tard donc il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de choses il ya aussi le coup
j'ai 3 qui est possible tous les coups
sont possibles dans cette position mais
un long cou qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui donc évidemment il ya les
voies principales et fouché 5
l'autre coup majeur c'est le coût 6
pouces et 4 l'idée de ce coup stéphane
et bien tout simplement le fou et en c4
il est absurde c'est donc en règle
générale nous n'allons jamais joué avec
eux 7 5 dans cette variante puisque le
fou sekkat serait trop bien placé il
faut donc en toute logique jouer avec
ie6 donc ça c'est la première chose
qu'elle est l'idée générale des blancs
après fou c4 il y en a eu ni un plan
d'attaqué simple stéphane qui est assez
dangereux mais forcé les noirs à jouer
au 6 mai un premier temps et ensuite
essayer de pilonner ce point aussi saint
jouan f4 puis f5 voilà amener un pion à
f/5 mettre la pression sur lyon aussi
cessé de le provoquer apprendront f5 ou
à avancer entre 5 et ensuite le fou dont
qui sera reculé sur la diagonale sur
cette grande diagonale et bien ce sera
extrêmement fort puisque impulsion aussi
cela casse des 5 sera complètement prise
par les pièces blanches
voilà donc le plan d'attaqué général les
blancs ça passe par f4 f5
mais il y en a d'autres il ya d'autres
possibilités pour les banques donc nous
allons tout de suite vous recommander
une stratégie à adopter avec les noirs
dans un premier temps le coup aussi
stéphane c'est une nécessité c'est
important puisque le plus accepter les
faibles quand même il peu susceptible
d'être attaqué des sacrifices de fous
sont possibles 800 donc il faut faire
attention dans cette position les blancs
peuvent jouer normal avec petit rock
tout de suite ils choisissent dans cette
partie qui est donc une partie nigel
short qui est un fervent défenseur de se
pousser 4 contre garry kasparov qui lui
est un adepte de la night of four b3
c'est le coup le plus généralement jouer
dans cette position
un coût tout à fait classique puisque de
toute façon les noirs vont quand même
joué b5 coin intéressant puisque sa
guigne de l'espace à l'aide d'armes ça
permet de développer le fossé mi temps
17 et ça permet aussi de voir des quatre
donc les blancs disent je joue foulée 3
avant que tu joues b5 en fait ça ne
change pas grand chose
wen or ces
ça leur est égal et continuent leurs
plans il fait 6 7 6 5
alors menace tout de suite b4 attaquons
le cavalier c3 et les 124 entreprises
alors il va falloir se méfier stefan wey
parce que cette note donc b4 que
lecavalier bouge et ensuite on prend un
point quatre est très très dangereuse il
faut il faut bien vous mettre en garde
ce pion ne sera que très très rarement
prenable
ça sera juste dans certains cas d'école
donc première ce qu'il faut dire dans
ces pays ont effectivement b4 et une des
idées des blancs mais ça peut être avec
l'idée de creuser 4 puits aux 5
une fois que le câliner plus en c3
puisque île peuplée sur la caste des
saints qui a beaucoup d'idées
ici les blancs ont plusieurs coups donc
on perd pas de temps à jouer à deux ou à
trois les blues jouent pas de votre nez
blanc chocolat 3 puisqu'il y aurait
refoulé 7 qui tout de suite at a créé
depuis quatre efforts seraient
vraisemblablement les blancs a joué avec
f2 f3 et à ce moment là il joue plus à 4
4 quand ils ont joué f3 donc ça c'est
très important si vous pouvez passif
éviter que les banques jouent avec
quatre minutes de route tout simplement
pas d' attaque et on rappelle les plans
classique
si les blancs ne font rien ces femmes il
ya une case clé dans cette position si
elle est assez 4 et donc on a plus qu à
transcrire le cavalier comme c'est aussi
vers la case c4 ça c'est dans
l'hypothèse qui n'est pas inenvisageable
où les blancs déciderait de jouer avec
f3 et donc se fermerait les options
d'attaqué avec elle quatre est donc en
gros pour résumer si les blancs ne font
rien eh bien vous vous allez faire
quelque chose année le cap des 8 sur la
casse et 4 ça c'est un plan évidemment
il faut 7 et patti rock il faut pas
négliger le développement dans les
ouvertures
ouais ici à nantes joue petit rock nigel
short chante petit rock et garry
kasparov dans cette position ne joue pas
b4 et quel point 4 qui est extrêmement
dangereux voilà pourtant ça a l'air
intéressant on va on va quand même le
regarder b4 en toute logique les blancs
viennent sur la terre à quatre cavaliers
pros 24 maintenant quatre ans et ici je
lui il ya des problèmes il ya des
problèmes dans beaucoup de beaucoup de
cas je sais bien que les blancs perdu
quand même temps
développement et les blancs peuvent en
profiter et notamment pour peut être
profiter la case b6 qui affaiblit sa ce
cavalier de sogessur cause b6 en jouant
peut-être fou ou trois fautes 3 c'est un
coup tout rond est un acte majeur
également que les noirs n'ont toujours
par ok donc il ya des parcs qui jouait
sur ce thème en tout cas c'est jouable
mais c'est très s'est tendue ces joueurs
mais on vous le déconseille puisque les
blancs sont complètement sur leur
terrain le joueur qui joue ses 4 contre
vous eh bien il connaît ça il a des
idées contre sept fils de pions et en
général il vaut mieux ne pas aller le
chercher
tout simplement c'est pas une bonne idée
fawcett coup tout à fait normal on se
dit peut-être le prendrais plus tard
pendant cette fois ci on ya plusieurs
plein de possibilités il ya notamment f4
est possible bref quatre avec idf1 qui
sont intéressants coûts directs et
l'autre idée c'est le coût de rs 3 qui
est le coût principal dans cette
position l'idée c'est de passer la dame
en g3 d'abord ensuite elle attaquera le
pion g7 et ensuite de jouer f4 f5
éventuellement ou alors des attaques
avec francis et jean roch est alors au
passage une petite menace les blancs
menace ne jouer peut être quatre cinq
il le menace certainement stéphane
puisque après eux 5
on voit que la dame est roi attac la
torah la classe parmi les options en
attaque le cavaly exactement donc pour
cela il y a beaucoup de solutions avec
les noirs
le coût principal dans cette position
ces dames c'est 7 mai nous vous
recommandons un autre coup qui a été le
choix de garry kasparov
c'est de jouer le coup d'un v6 alors des
mais si c'est pas tout à fait pareil
puisque normalement la dame on la met en
scène puisqu'elle est bien placé dans ce
set ne risque pas de se faire attaquer
et les blancs n'ont pas le couffo droit
enfin il ya une idée derrière dam des
six premières pointes ça tacle qui est
des cartes et si les plans dans cette
position j'ai eu 5 stéphane nous jouons
d'abord fondé cette fougue et cette voix
là parce que l'ademe en b6 contrôler la
case l'es7 il faut bessette et après en
bouche de plein fouet trois où l'on
prend le pion très logique contre menace
donc nouvelles menaces
hier qu'on voit le fou qui est apte la
dame d'un tacle à tour donc l'amener à
sky prend ainsi ses 36 hockey éprouvé
simple comprendre monsieur cavaliers
toutes les découvertes de cavaliers
c'est sur le principe
d'une attaque à la découverte des
composants de qualité de foie tacle adam
donc c'est inacceptable et maintenant
tout dame bessette
alors quand on voit ça c'est des fans on
se dit qu'est ce qui fait kasparov
ouais ben ça c'est par l'idc d'attaqués
depuis le 4 je pense c'est à dire que la
dame effectivement attaque le plan 4
avec le clavier fils et on n'a pas bougé
le fou c8 qui continue à contrôler la
case de 6 voilà ça c'est très très
important c'est que le fou on n'a pas
toujours envie de le mettre en 17 à
cause de cette fille ce potentiel sur le
pion aux 6 et d'ailleurs on peut y
revenir
bien avant après le ku'damm f3 dans
cette question surtout bessette et bien
fondées 7 serait une faute puisqu'ils
durent fo prend aussi il y aurait
peut-être faut prendre six mètres sans
aucun doute vous pourrez aussi c'est un
coup très fort dans cette position en
tout cas très intéressant parce que ça
prend en moins ça prend trois pions qui
avait dû prendre la dame doit bouger le
québec va prendre l'option g7 avec échec
enregistre sur la case et le roi n'a
plus de défense
exactement le plus de pions de défense
sacrifice thématique est ici ça gagne en
ligne donc c'est une des idées de 9,3
bonjour dam des six dons car notre
sang-froid fou 3 et dames bessette
maintenant attaques qui ont eu qu'à le
pousser vite comme tu l'as dit stéphane
garde le contrôle du kronos il ya plus
de sacrifices de ce côté là et
maintenant nous regardons dame g3 assez
logique attaque l'option g7 b4 contre
attaque contre attaque parce qu'on
attaque le quai et c3 sur d'un projet
c'est ton jour et tours j'ai vite torché
vite avec la tour qui attaquent le pion
g2 voilà et la dame en embuscade
voilà on vient on n'aurait plus qu'à
prendre le cavalier ouais tout
simplement cavalli à 4 maintenant on
peut prendre ce pion au 4 mai c'est
toujours extrêmement bas sur tout le
projet s'est toujours en prise comme 8
faire attention
exactement c'est à dire que si on prend
de la dame il ya qu'à valider si ce qui
est très ennuyeux si on prend du
cavalier il ya d'approcher cette qui est
extrêmement redoutable qu'est ce qu'on
peut plus jouer tour g8 comme à la
cavale est un 24 donc dans cette
position nous serons très simplement
cavaliers b17 donc on laisse le plonger
cette emprise
on laisse le purger cette entrevue n'a
pas peur non puisque dans cette position
sur dame projet cette 11e tour dangereux
tour g8 tout simplement tout rejet midi
après damage 6 d'empreintes quatre robes
le mans qui menacent matin j'ai 2
exactement avec une excellente position
pour les noirs puisqu'au coup
d'apprendre à jouer d'un objet 6 sans
doute échange les dames reprendre du
pillon h structure de pions bien compact
et aucun affaiblissement de la position
dans cette position traquer et b17 vous
êtes assez tranquille vous êtes forcé
les blancs a joué le coup f2 f3
puisqu'ici nous ils vont perdre le pion
de 4 et maintenant qu'ils ont joués 3
est bien très simplement vous sortez vos
pièces avec petit rock est une très très
belle position donc ici maintenant on va
faire la minute du connaisseur pour
détailler cette position qui est un
grand classique et plus de 50 parties
jouées dans cette même position
un plan des noirs c'est de mettre le
cavalier en bo5
sachant que les plantes peuvent pas
jouer quatre puisque puis enquête étant
prises donc ça c'est une possibilité
pour cela il faut blinder la case b6
pour éviter de se prendre des caisses b6
avec combinaison et pour blinder la
casse v6 on joue généralement tourbe
élite dames ces sept on replace les
pièces comme ça contraint de la case b6
et ensuite cavalier aux 5 eca les c4
voilà les plans pour les noirs le fou
ces huit vallées sur la case 17
très logiquement pour garder le contrôle
lupion aussi c'est avoir un petit oeil
sur le cavalier arnal sur le cavalier à
4 les blancs eux vont tenter de jouer le
pion c est dès qu'ils seront c'est bush
qui lie ans et 4 ans et 3 vous le prenez
en passant avec une position tout à fait
équilibrée voilà donc pour cette
première partie qui est une partie très
intéressante pour la théorie
on va la revoir rapidement mais on a un
deuxième exemple qui va nous permettre
de revenir sur les veines donc tout est
parti jeudi de pôle gare contre bruce
dancefloor stéphane je crois que tu es
un fan de j'ai dit oh là et bien tout le
monde est fan de vue des polaires donc
je crois qu'elle est d'ailleurs tout
récemment entrée dans le club des vingt
premiers mondiaux qu'elle avait quitté
un temps il
revenu au premier plan judit polgar donc
avec et blanc contre bourhis qu'elle
fonde énorme joueur donne âge d'or il a
joué ça depuis qu'il est tout petit donc
il la connaît très bien eux quatre ces
cinq les premiers coups sont les mêmes
que les trois des six des quatre pions
prend des quatre caves des brancardiers
si ce qu'elle sait 3 à 6 pouces et cap
c'est le fameux coup de 6 petit rock
donc là au lieu de foot de 3 petit rock
mais après p5 ça le change nous sommes
tous fous rires ça joue ça change pas
grand chose
alors dans cette position on vous le
rappelle on ne veut pas jouer sous 17
pardon je veux pas jouer au foot et 7
puisque s'affaiblit puis aussi ça permet
faut prendre si pas totale dans cette
position a tout de suite en tout cas les
nouvelles et blanc pour jouer avec
at-elle 5 avec une attaque énorme contre
ce pion petit donc ont tout faux cette
dame est roi c'est une tentative on
verra les autres tentatives tout à
l'heure ici là on ne joue vraiment pas
fou 17 puisqu'il ya le sacrifice en
aussi bon mais parce que même sans
l'appui en g7 n'est plus défendu exact
après que le cavaliere reprend prend le
pion g7 avec les chèques ont ajouté mme
b 6 contre attaque sur lequel des quatre
et en étant sûr au simplon avoue
bessette qui contre attaque la dalle
full 3 est maintenant levé la dame sur
la case 17 important donc on a résolu le
problème de la torah vite jouée dans un
premier temps les blanches d'alger 3
alors ici très important il ne faut pas
que les banques jouent avec 4,5 ça c'est
hyper important
on joue donc d4 chasse le cavaly ces
trois cavaliers à 4 et cavaliers b17 ça
c'est pour le contrôle de la case des
six puisque si on joue petit rock dans
cette question stéphane il ya un
problème immédiat c'est je crois qu'à
valider si ce que nous allons vérifier
tout de suite comme libé signe je crois
que ce coût est assez fort puisque sur
dame prend b6 il y a calibre en hausse 6
ou 4,5 au choix avec kerviel 5 et pas
mal qui attaquent la dame et qui
menacent matinée ce matériel tout ça dès
fort désagréable donc après il ya quatre
ans vous qui avez 17 protégeant la casse
b6 et en même temps le pion g7 étant
prises puis sur l'a10 à tours j'ai vite
et d'apprendre 4 donc nous continuons
f3c nous avons forcé les blancs ajourés
f3 maintenant nous faisons petit rock et
là il y à un piège puisque votre
adversaire peut être tenté de jouer six
mois menace matt non à ce match eux qui
paieront ligne on va voir ça perd de
manière fort c'est donc là
c'est l'occasion pour vous stephen enfin
pour vous internautes de gagner une
partie facile
ouais ici on joue quadrillage cinq
attaques la dame défense g7 des fonds g7
et attaque la dame
la dame vient sur la case h3 puisque sur
dame g4 nous devons donc validé un f6
les deux cavaliers en défense duo de
cavaliers donc extrêmement puissant ont
peu on peut vous montrer cette
possibilité d' alger quatre cavaliers
des sur la case f6 attaque la dame la
dame doit encore quitté fin doit rester
dans clouage justement pour que les
noirs de piste à fond et maintenant il
suffit de jouer par exemple 3 h 8 qui a
l'air de gagner tout simplement le fou
ne peut plus partir une fois que le
fruit est en prison voilà donc le fou et
un prix c'est la première chose qu'ils
avaient 10 h cinq attaques la dame sur
des objets cats et c'est pas possible
damages trois contre attaques sur la vie
h5 mais là on prend quand même le fou
d'amour en cavalier et maintenant la
petite pointe qui vous fait marquer le
point damas est le couple clouage de
cavaliers des 4 et les menaces aux 5 et
menaçe 5 donc les blancs défendre le
cavalier est maintenue suffit d'attaquer
avec un pion il est toujours flou et
donc il peut plus bouger
pour résumer ce qui s'est passé après
damas sept oncles ou le cavalier et les
blancs ne peuvent pas simultanément le
défendre et le des clous et joli joli
parcours d'un homme alors dame b système
mais cette dame à 7
c'est un parcours ce coup des dames
petit parcours efficace est hyper fort
efficace voilà donc un piège que vous
pouvez placer vos adversaires tout à
fait agréable dans cette position parce
qu'elles font judit polgar à continuer
ça c'est agréable mais la partie n'a
fait aucun doute
après le gain de la pièce cette position
est totalement gagnante pour les noirs
une partie suivante stéphane donc qui
est dans un autre une autre
variante une autre thématique une partie
du grand bobby qui a les blancs qui
jouent contre smith l'offre que tu peux
peut-être nous présenter un petit peu ma
smith la photo a été champion du monde
en 58 et monsieur ghosn hier soir mon
sens et qui a été de nouveau finaliste
des candidats contre kasparov en 80 et
donc
31 ans a fait vingt ans après maintenant
après donc smith love c'est un grand nom
des chèques commandés ce qui est
aujourd'hui assez âgées vassili smirnov
c5 qualif 3e 6
donc c'est un autre homme de goût des
captures prend le quatrième rang des
quatre sonates ça ne commence pas comme
une hache d'or vous allez voir qu'on est
dans la même position des six pouces et
quatre fuglseth petit rock à 6 foot b3
b5 f4 donc là voilà le plan le
changement ce n'est plus d'âme f3 qui
est adopté c'est un autre coup c'est le
coup f4 don qui est beaucoup plus direct
d'un steven f 4 c'est vraiment je vais
te explosé je vais jeter la case aussi
ce jeu toi explose donc bobby fischer
dans son style très incisif toujours
petit rock calme olympien de la ceni
smith l'ofs les blancs ici doivent
justifier ce qu'ils font donc si par
exemple il joue un coup léger comme dame
f3 et bien nous serons vraisemblablement
qu'est ce que nous vivons sur damestoy
bien phu b c est probablement fouler
cette exactement avec la manade b4 le
client à quatre reprises donc
composition tout à fait jouable f5
c'est clairement dans l'idée des blancs
et si stéphane il faut savoir très
précisément comment réagir quand on se
prend s5
ouais bah oui parce que le joueur qui
n'a jamais vu ce genre de choses est
hanté par exemple de prendre 9 5
ouais ouais mais ça ça réveille trop le
foot est roi c'est une faute ça me
réveille énormément foulée 3 et en plus
ça permet aux cahiers des cadres devenus
sur la case et 5 qui est des cas de
procure en 1905 elle est très bien très
bien passé ensuite ça donne la case
dessins auxquels ces trois ans ouais ok
c'est 3 pourra venir s'installer là bref
très mauvaise réaction sur l'app store
c'est la prise
on sait de la plus mauvaise surtout
qu'on le fouet la deuxième réaction
envisagée ne rien faire wayne mais là
c'est pas possible on ne peut pas
défendre le tourisme ouais mais peut
aussi se veut être pris une douche si on
peut le défend à la limite c'est pas
tout c'est une solution intermédiaire
qui est peut être une solution
d'attentes
ici c'est pas possible pas troisième
solution jouait aux cinq solutions qui
al'air catastrophique et il serait
vraiment
puisque le cas les c3 viendrait sur la
caste des cinq très prochainement tout
de suite mais prochainement donc smith
l'homme joue d'habitude on tout de suite
ils pourraient ils pourraient y aller
tout de suite harry pour y aller tout de
suite c'est l'heure si haut si elle
imagine en a eu cinq voiliers de la
vallée des seynes oui c'est par exemple
sur canal il prend alors surpris quand
même s'ils ont pris les points quand il
faut faire attention
effectivement ça c'est pas possible
centif d'avoir bougé les cavaliers nombe
4 non je pensais enfin bon moment et
variantes et moi et je pensais la
fumeuse de 4,11 chasse d'abord le key c3
puisque la sûreté on prend aussi c'est
bien on prend le cavaly donc avec une
pièce de plus un une case de plus c'est
synonyme d'un gain technique cavalli ce2
gens poussent en u15 va maintenant
maintenant voilà que lecavalier ne peut
plus revenir sur la case dessin
exactement le cas et cette voie est déjà
parti n'ira donc plus sur la caisse des
5 et donc tout l'enjeu de cette position
il est très simple est ce que les noirs
réussir - jouer des 5 ou pas ou est ce
qu'ils se feront bloqué est ici smith
l'ofs apporte une touche dans sa réponse
puisque après qu'edf 3 il ne prend pas
tout de suite le pion de 4 ce qui serait
assez ce qui est possible mais assez
dangereux mais il est indemne d cinglant
aux fous des 5
oui mais il ya des possibilités de jouer
au foot 17 avec dmb six échecs qui
récupère mais on préfère pratiquement
tout le temps je vous trouvez cette wii
2 ça sent le pion mrd l'attaqué voilà le
pion est perdu et le fou est bien placé
sur cette diagonale tout à fait en plus
on contrevient accueille maintenant on
n'a plus peur de sur la case aussi
puisque le cavaly des caps n'est plus
présent donc le foot ap sur la case f7
mais oui des blogs quand même bien
défendus sadien descendu pour l'instant
dans cette position qu est ce qu il faut
voir et le four b3 et fort que le foot
est roi est assez fort c'est vrai c'est
pour ça qu'on va essayer de prendre 4 et
trouver des cinq après pour boucher sous
donc sg3 défense qu'elle 10.4 quand même
cavalli pont phu prompt et ici on peut
dire que les noirs sont devenus ouais
mais c'est pas facile à jouer par il
faut faire attention surtout contre
fischer ont faim smith mais elle a fini
par transformer l'essai après damien fou
pour un f3 tour pour un f3 qui essaient
6 ça c'est la partie s'est déroulée très
bien
pour smictom avec une position solide de
défense il faut faire très attention aux
pièces des blanches qui coulisse quand
même sur les colonnes hug vers le roi
noir mais ici vous pouvez vous défendre
une autre partie dans les variantes et
ce sera une des dernières pratiques nous
verrons dans cette émission c'est une
partie à nandy vente souk donc ouverture
totalement similaire encore le plan avec
f4 donc nous allons dérouler des coûts
bien connus assez rapidement à 6 pouces
et théâtre aussi ce petit rat fawcett
dont contre les mêmes coûts petit rock
enjoué b5 aussi efficace que normalement
on aurait préféré jouer des saints et
des saintes maintenant est simple et f5
encore une fois ouais alors des quatre
toujours chasser lecavalier avant tout
aux cinq jours thématique tentative de
ivantchouk il dit moi je mets le
cavalier sur la case à quatre et non pas
sur la case de nous fâcher les réseaux
de bon et bien réfutation d'aaland eu
cinq cavaliers 2 maintenant on a une
voix là son idée c'est que il veut
peut-être laissé la case d3 libre pour
la tour on ne sait pas trop quelle est
l'idée du match mais en tout cas à
nantes n'a pas pris de but en quatre il
a bien fait puisque à une variante forcé
qui donne l'avantagé aux plantes
il a joué fou bessette tout à fait
bienvenu dans cette voie et maintenant
il y avait foule des cinq qui marchait
parce que on peut tout jouer d'un v6
échec
exactement c'est une femme ailée prend
1,4 kg 3 kg 3 kebede cette voie express
pas de prendre l'option dont il va tout
simplement ne pas le prendre dans cette
partie pour une raison très simple c'est
que le jeu des blancs avec cette
structure là il tourne autour de la
caisse des cinq mais là ils peuvent pas
l'utiliser lecavalier a capté trop loin
on voit pas comment les blancs peuvent
se replacer pour revenir sur cette caste
des cinq l'autre plan c'est de pousser
le plonger ne peux pas mais il peut pas
donc dans cette position stratégique man
les noirs ont déjà gagné la partie
maintenu voire suffit de sortir les
pièces intelligemment
c'est ce que fait évidemment oui jma un
tannant d'après damien à 5
c'est le 4ème protège les quatre
tentatives vivent en dessous qui ne sert
à rien d'annoncer cette dame deux tours
fc lui donc vous voyez des coups simples
tout simplement
pour jouer cette position ensuite ça va
jouer avec peut-être qu'elle est c'est
simple peut-être fou ccif peut-être fois
ci pour attaquer ses cadres beaucoup de
plans pour les noirs ce position est
très bonne pourquoi parce que les blancs
n'ont pas de plan d' attaque fort
dernières parties anand kasparov donc là
c'est chaud c'est une variante force et
très technique on va vous la montrer les
trains décidé cat way up à 6 pouces et
4-6 6-7 7 4 des 5 dans cette position
donc nous avons vu le coup f5 et un coût
est maintenant ici laisser forcer c'est
le cou aux 4,5
ouais donc un 1 2 30e 50e kasparov c'est
un plan différent qui n'a absolument
rien à voir
puis on prend 1,5 j'en prends cavaliers
f
en 17 ouais une fois ta question plus
vite donc ici il n'ya pas de combinaison
rien de particulier à nantes choisi le
goût d'un match 5 donc on voit qu'il ya
des idées de pression en fait stéphane
ce qu'on menace de prendre 7 sans doute
avec la tour et ensuite je fou prend 2,6
on menace également peut-être cabaye
prend aussi des rires il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de pression et beaucoup de
choses sur la case de 6 l'idée d'un
machin c'est bien entendu que ça des
champions 5
et là vous avez à votre disposition et
heureusement d'ailleurs un coup fort
c'est un coût qui force les événements
c'est le couscous et 5 clouage alors
c'est pas mal parce que bon ça pour une
pièce mais c'est surtout la pièce qui
attaquent aussi ça cloue une pièce très
important là une pièce qui est donc
centralisée qui attaquent exception aux
6 et en même temps de laclos et stéphane
autre avantage ça l'attaquent
ouais ça n'attaque pas c'est pas mal non
plus donc forcé foule 3 maintenant dans
cette position donc les noirs doivent
trouver quelque chose et kasparov à la
clé de l'énigme c'est à dire que si on a
rien à faire si on ne sait pas quoi
faire avec les noirs dans cette question
le plan des blancs il est très simple
stéphane ça va être tour f 4 way tour h4
et mat pour voir même touré font autour
f3 tour g3
bref c'est ce qu'on appelle monter les
tours à l'attack c'était j'ai très très
fort 1 c'est fort quand on se retrouve
avec deux tours une dame un cavalier un
fou un deuxième four devant le roi ne
faut pas perdre de temps il faut pas
perdre de temps il faut agir rapidement
et vous avez un peu forcé vous donnez la
paire de fou prend des quatre fonds
prend des 4 et caresser 6 avec un gain
de temps gain de temps échange de pièces
donc ça c'est bien ça favorise la
défense et en plus ce gain de pions
parce que ici on menace de prendre en d4
et ensuite de jouer d'amd si ce qui
serait tout à fait désagréable donc il
faut retirer le foufou 3 est maintenant
cavalier c'est prend pion aux 5 avec une
position complexe mais où vous avez pris
un pion ouais mais surtout maintenant le
cavalier peut revenir en défense angers
6 voilà ça c'est l'autre travaillé pour
revenir un f6 donc c'est très bien
qu'aucun lien fils est idéal pour la
défense du roi et inclut en plus c'est
juste donc ici vous avez tous les
éléments pour bien vous défendre pour
tenir cette position donc tout
simplement bien qu'à sport n'a pas
transformé l'essai mais vous vous le
ferez sans doute
voilà donc pour cette variante avec fous
ces quatre n'était pas alors pour
résumer
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire c'est une
position les noirs doivent jouer quand
même très précis ouais euh 6 ne pas
jouer au foot mais c'est trop tôt oui
pour éviter des sacrifices en
réussissent et surtout pas oublier de
pas prendre le pian de4 s'il ya un prix
d'autres autour non plus voilà alors il
faut faire très attention quand on veut
prendre l'option de 4 il vaut mieux
l'attaqué peut le prendre c'est plus
fort les réactions sur f5
c'est généralement bécade su-25 il faut
d'abord gcc 3 on va renvoyer tout ça
tranquillement jouer les positions en
famille puisque elles sont toutes très
intéressant
et on vous donne rendez-vous donc après
l'été puisque là d'une petite pause pour
tout le mois d'août on vous donne rendez
vous pour une nouvelle leçon ce n'est
pas exactement
merci de nous avoir suivis